others may hate you those who hate you
don't win unless you hate them and then
you destroy yourself that was Richard
Nixon's parting advice to his staff
moments before he left the White House
for the last time as the president of
the United States
it's been almost 43 years since his
historic resignation and while mr.
Nixon's time in office may have ended in
shame a new book argues he had an
outsized influence on our world today
Richard Nixon the life is being praised
as a definitive biography of the
nation's 37th President when we're
pleased to be joined by its author John
a Ferrell John welcome thanks for being
here ah any time let's start with a
president taking a trip to Saudi Arabia
and in the middle of a crisis we you
think there any an analogy it's Richard
Nixon in fact did in 1974 he did in the
summer of 1974 he took off he did
several foreign policy
trips he had one of his last summits
with Soviet leaders and basically he did
it for good reasons but also as part of
a distraction and it didn't work it
didn't work it did not work no no nine
two months later he resigned a month
later at night you know in 1972 he went
to China that was a big deal he signed a
salt treaty with the Soviet Union that
was a big deal and that influenced
people before they went to the polls in
1972 but you know I can't foresee the
president Trump will bring anything like
that back from this trip well John the
parallels between what's going on in the
Trump White House and what happened in
the Nixon White House are almost eerie
let's just start with this week yeah the
invocation of the word witch-hunt to
describe what the president feels is
happening regarding the Russia
investigation
President Nixon used the same words
where did the sense of grievance come
from Sensa grievance in Nixon's case
came from a very Dickensian childhood he
grew up but there's a picture in the
book of the Euro Berlinda where he grew
up and it looks like the Badlands of
Oklahoma during the midst of the Dust
Bowl days his father was a abuse
emotionally abusive fella his mother was
very very cold and as Nixon famously
said never in my life that she ever told
me that she loved me so that kind of
grievance was sort of fueled then when
he gets into the campaigns against the
Kennedy's and other Ivy League tops
types and he begins to think of himself
as the the common man the forgotten
American which we heard a lot from
President Trump actually we actually
heard forgotten American this week from
president from John talk to me a little
bit about about how President Nixon's
party reacted to him through the
Watergate crisis because initially the
Conservatives didn't like Richard Nixon
no they didn't and he actually has this
little star of his own up in the
celestial celestial sky of politics
because the Conservatives would have
moved on to reaganism in a more
right-wing stance and liberals will
never like Richard Nixon so he sort of
floats around by by himself but but his
party stuck with him right till the very
end till we had what was known as the
smoking gun tape came out in the end of
as a resort as the result of a Supreme
Court decision in July 1974 and then
Barry Goldwater and Hugh Scott and John
Rhodes went up to the White House they
met with him and they said we don't have
the votes to stop impeachment in the
house and you're going to get convicted
in the Senate and that's when he decided
to leave and one of Nixon's relationship
to his staff a Donald Trump this week it
was revealed that he had been having
conversations directly with Michael
Flynn even though he was under
investigation Donald Trump had a
conversation with HR Haldeman it sounds
like there were a similar connection
conversation yeah Richard Nixon yeah
Nixon never said anything like this that
this is from this morning's times I just
fired the head of the FBI I faced great
pressure because of Russia that's taken
off it took Nixon until after he
resigned was on David Frost to say
something that was sort of that
incriminating or self that kind of a
self indictment so we're this whole
thing has been compressed into 120 days
we've had cover-up tape impeachment all
the massacre in the last week I mean
it's a speeded-up version yeah John
Farrell thank you so much for being with
us Richard Nixon the life the book is
available now it's a fascinating read